welcome back to new rockstars shangchi's
trailer is here right before the falcon
the winter soldiers finale so
how will this disney plus series set up
the mcu beyond this final episode
to the upcoming bigger titles like
shanghai like black widow
is it pretty much guaranteed that john
walker will say something offensive and
piss off everyone in the ten rings
i think so i i think that guy does not
care about his words that closely and
uh the tin rings you do not want to
offend them uh i'm eric voss this is
rogue theory with me today to go rogue
is friend of the show comedian and
writer jessica clemens
hi hi welcome back so good to have you
back
i'm so happy to be back i'm gonna put on
these sunglasses
does that make my outfit look cooler oh
yeah i like this is a look okay i'm
going to keep them
just keep adding things throughout the
show it's just going to get better and
better yeah let's get going what's going
on
perfect also with us to return to the
show from gamertag radio and kind of
funny network paris lily welcome back
hey thank you so much for having me back
again really excited for today's topic
yeah i'm excited as well and uh rounding
out the panel friend of the show return
to guest tom michelson
how's it fam um i don't have any glasses
like jessica but i got my winter soldier
uh hoodie on so i'm ready to talk some
cap
a little bit of a blood blood on my cap
shield getting ready for this finale
oh my god let's do it i'm ready you are
geared up and ready to go
all right so let's talk about the falcon
winner soldier and uh shanghi
and how they might be connected so
shangchi in the legend of the ten rings
they released his trailer
introducing us to shanghi and his father
win woo aka the mandarin who's the
leader of the criminal empire known as
the ten rings and
right now we're kind of looking at the
finale of the falcon the winter soldier
which
is a series with a lot of loose ends
regarding the southeast asian
criminal haven of madrapore and the
mysterious power broker
now maybe by the time you are watching
this episode of rogue theory you might
have some answers to some of these
questions
uh but how is the falcon and the winter
soldier setting up
all the big chapters ahead for the mcu
uh characters like chongqi uh like uh
natasha romanov and black widow even
though that's going to be set earlier it
seems like a show like the fact in the
winter soldier
is a very grounded story so it's going
to be setting up things like
chongqi like a secret invasion perhaps
so i want to hear from you guys how do
you think
how do you think this series is really
opening up the mcu to
these corners of stories that are set on
earth well i think that
um there is there's especially from that
trailer there's so many things that you
could
gleam off of that tie into different
parts of the mcu like even just little
moments of like
well that warrior battle like their
weapons are glowing and it's like is
that like kind of like mordo's
um you know the staff that he had where
he could imbue it with some
magic and um and never mind you know the
thing you've already pointed out on the
show about that maybe going back to
madrapore and so
i think that yeah this is gonna i think
that maybe the end of the show is gonna
try to set some c's for some things
coming up um and one of the things i was
thinking is that you know i do agree i
think they're going back to madrid
and i wonder if magibor is actually
maybe the mandarin's hq
where he operates his criminal empire
out of because you know that's a that's
a kind of a lawless place where maybe he
can operate without any interference
he has access all the deadliest
assassins on the planet maybe some of
them even helped train
uh shang chi and then and then that way
as when woo you know maybe this
public-facing
non-criminal persona he could move
freely throughout the world without
people really realizing
that he's a mandarin and that could
explain why an evil organization like
aim
didn't even know he was real you know um
and and then you know there's precedent
for that too and other things like how
lex luthor can become president even
though he's like a super villain because
he's got kind of those two personas yeah
so i wonder i think that i think that we
might be seeing
a lot of without realizing it some some
some of the groundwork for the future of
the mcu coming through
yeah i would build off of exactly what
you're saying
that i i think a lot of this is we're
gonna find out that the mandarin
has been touching everything in the mcu
the entire time and like you said with
madrid
i mean this is just this criminal place
where
a lot of criminals and activity and
things happen and
i think the tie that could bring this
back into the falcon and winter soldier
he very well may be the power broker or
the power broker
is associated with the mandarin and then
we find out that sharon carter as an
extension is probably
involved somehow um because the whole
thing with the mandarin if we take this
all the way back to the beginning of the
mcu
it's about power what was the ten rings
trying to do they wanted the stark
attack
right when we look at the falcon and
wonder soldier what is the power broker
trying to do
he wants the super soldier serum because
it's power so
you you tie that into the 10 rings and
just everything that's going with him
he's assembling all the power in the
world
because ultimately he's going to make
his big play at some point is is my
assumption here and then chung chi
i always screw up the name wrong so i do
apologize for
um obviously plays into this because
they've they've changed his origin a
little bit that it's the mandarin son so
now we're probably going to have that
whole vader luke skywalker moment with
them
and he's going to be in opposition to
what the mandarin
is is attempting to do with his crimes
index so so yeah i think his tentacles
are
everywhere in the mcu just just touching
everything
i mean i think that is the most uh
satisfying answer to who is the power
broker now again
i could be wrong that's kind of been the
theory drum i've been beating is like
uh i just think the power broker feels
like a mandarin type figure even though
the power broker could be anyone it
could be just some unknown person
um i just think like if you're gonna
reveal it to be someone else we know in
the mcu
someone involved with the ten rings
knowing that the ten rings is gonna be
in another movie this year seems like
the most apt way to go
uh based off what we already know the
ten rings to be what you guys have been
saying
um but uh yeah i think it is and
the the ten rings answering that
question of who's the real mandarin
is a question that marvel fans have had
since iron man 3
uh and since that all hail the king
short like the way they had trevor
slattery it felt like a joke but it
really short changed
the coolness of the mandarin and what
they could be it felt like iron man
the movie's kind of backed away from
that and now shang chi like uh
again i just said shang chi because it's
still in my head trying to try to get it
right
shang chi shung chi feels like they
could answer in a way that um
gets people really excited for what's
coming next i just want to say really
quick
because i already said it before i'm
really sleepy i just woke up so i'm
sorry i'm talking very slow
okay we got you we got you i'm so tired
it's not because it's 4
20.
so i agree with everyone
i think i agree but i also disagree
because this is a
theory okay so i think okay so i think
magic is a big connection like obviously
it's like we're all
crime is so it's like of course the
mandarin has his hands in it but i also
don't think
it's his like i don't think he's the
power broker i think i what i would love
to see sharon carter being the power
broker
and she's i want her to be a good person
so i do want her to be working
undercover so deep that she somehow got
into the mandarins level of the ten
rings
but i don't know if that's that's
plausible because that man is
ancient and has been uh he knows
everything he's god-like
so i do think that magic is going to be
a big connection but i think the big
connection for match report is literally
just the estranged sister
he's just going to magical to go find
the sister i think the sisters in the
heart of it all
and so that's why we see that fight
scene in the middle i think that um
there obviously there's going to be a
lot of crime there but that's also where
the sister's laying low and trying to be
on the hideout
so i think when chang
we're all pronouncing it completely
wrong or right one of us must be right
um when he shows up there that's why
he's just doing that fight scene with
his sister
i think that madge report is just gonna
be like the side part
it's gonna be like oh remember this from
falcon winter soldier
yeah he has crime people here too but i
think
when with your um breakdown boss that
castle that he took over
millions of years ago will be that
castle that they're using as the
headquarters
yeah yeah or not millions well millions
of humans
yeah maybe 2 billion 2 billion
so you guys give me a break and so
i'm drinking a cold brew and uh and a
celebratory 2021 graduation cup i
graduated in 2016.
so i think that i think that should have
boss
i think that's going to be the main part
um but i i i
mean with that i feel like my theory is
kind of lame to be like
sharon is probably just being there
trying to do undercover stuff
madrapore is literally just there for
the sister but i do think that
he's so big that we have to give the
mandarin such a
big like entrance that i don't think i
think mad magic works too small
i think it's going to be like it got it
has to be huge
i'll just say just going following up
what you're saying about madrid because
you do bring up a great point as far as
that that wouldn't be
the mandarin's headquarters so to speak
because obviously again
er great breakdown that you had the
castle and everything that that we
already saw
that's most likely where his his origin
his base
is going to be but i i kind of think of
madrid poor as
and i keep using star wars references
i'm sorry but the tatooine
of the mce yeah yeah i know yeah this
kind of gives us the place where all the
criminals go
we're all how many of you are going yeah
exactly so i agree with it maybe that's
it
but now i am going to push back a little
bit on your sharon carter thing because
i truly hope she isn't really undercover
and and just this is the deepest of deep
fakes of all time
i hope she has just completely broke bad
i hope that war made her go you know
what
screw you guys you guys all got off i'm
just it's like deep cover if you
remember that movie with larry fishburne
back in the 90s but
she started off a good guy and now she's
a she's she's a villain i i really hope
that you know i i think that would be an
interesting twist and
a different look at a character we
already know i'd want her to be the
villain but i don't
think she which is people are gonna come
at me feel free
i don't think she is capable of like the
manner
he those people are just murderers
they're just killers
like they don't need like a motive so
it's like she's so you're just gonna
start killing people recklessly i feel
like you still have an
ounce of like morality in your heart
so i don't know if they're reckless they
seem pretty precise in their targets
they didn't kill tony stark they knew to
use tony stark to build them
an another super weapon like uh and she
was pretty john wick vicious in those
shipyards let's admit that's a new side
of sharon jordan we had seen
but those were bad people i don't know i
feel like in the comics he seemed more
like ruthless
to be fair i was going off the comics
that are not being combined to the new
series i don't think i think we're going
because i was reading like the 1975
ones where i'm like this isn't even the
same person so but
he just seems like not remorse like he
has no remorse i really like i really
like the idea about the sister i hadn't
thought about that and that would be
really fun if the sister was
the power broker because one of the
things that i didn't like if the power
broker
is someone we already know like let's
say it's the mandarin well he's a
mandarin and the power broker you know
or
carter and it's a power broker it's like
it would be fun if it was maybe someone
new
that we didn't know but also i don't
think it would be i don't think it would
be
like a like a not well-known actor like
how they you know dr nagle like it
probably is going to be somebody well
known but also maybe not be a
a-list reveal that because they just did
that with the last episode
um one theory i wanted to um i wanted to
propose if you will maybe even a rogue
theory if you will
if we're going off of that theory that
it's gonna be somebody we already know
um i think that there could be somebody
that we've already met
that has the resources and the reach and
just so happens to have some connections
to the mandarin that could be the power
broker
and someone who i would think would be
so fun to see
i really want and i hope the power
broker is justin hammer
and here's why so you know at the end of
the all of the all hail the king spot we
saw that he was at seagate
with you know trevor slattery um and
maybe when he got broken out maybe he
was able to escape too
uh running off and maybe he ran up to
madrid and since losing the arms race
really to tony as far as enhancing
people with armor
you know he could have shifted into
enhancing people with the serum
you know or other ways and that's how he
kind of became this power broker now he
gets to live it up and be rich
at that club dancing every night you
know probably complimentary lollipops
out the door yeah you know
rockwell's gonna work it yeah yeah and
and the other thing i
remembered is that you know um he uh
you know one of the things that he did
in iron man 2 is he flew in ice cream
from san francisco
and you know what's one of the most
famous desserts in sf
ghirardelli's which was in the the shang
shang chi see i'm saying around to the
trailer there you go there's two
different
connections yep oh it's good one of your
connections is
i it would be a fun thing if that turned
out to be it
but i i'm still holding on to dear life
that it's zola
i want it to be zombo
he is someone but then he's no one at
the same time because right
yeah this entire time and he's been
the one that's been been manipulating
everything and then maybe the mandarin
is you know associated with them to
bring that tie in but yeah it's going to
be interesting reveal
once we get that on who the power broker
is what are the motivations
why are why is he or she doing what
they're doing
but um yeah it's it's going to i love
the zola theory too but i was
thinking about it more yeah i'm like i
don't want to be mephisto again like
because i was so happy
train from day one but i'm just saying
like you know what like and zola would
make sense because he's tied to captain
america in that story and i love how in
this show
they're working in so many parts from
the score uh from henry jackman's score
to
other side characters and and to bring
him back with the body and the tv
oh sign me up that would be that would
be legit to bring him back as the body
with the tv
i'm gonna steal one half of tom's theory
and i want to believe it's the sister
now
because i'd be really sick because i
feel like this is that was your theory i
was repeating it yeah
okay so never mind you guys i didn't
steal tom's theory it was my theory so
i would love for the power broker to end
up being the sister and we see that
in september i know that's so i feel
like they're gonna release
who the power broker is by the sixth
episode for sure but
if they don't then i'm gonna hold on to
that that
balloon that it's the sister and that'd
be really tight because she's trying to
get redemption
i'm gonna be super surprised if when
we're watching this episode tonight
you know um that if they reveal anybody
that we
just saw in in the shanghai trailer in
the episode just because like
tony leong is a big name in a lot of
films these actors
and if it's if it's just someone who's
like oh you had to remember them from
the trailer
i think people would be like wait hold
on who's that actor but if it's just
like the ten rings logo
i think that's something that marvel
fans would be like holy [ __ ] shang chi
was all about that
oh my god uh i can't punish myself i'll
get there i'll get there but man zola oh
my god look guys i was looking out for
zola clues
all all episodes of this series but at
no point was like technology or
surveillance technology or at any point
did a webcam
crane around or anything if that had
happened you know i would have been all
over it
but like you know with juan division we
had several clues pointing to witchcraft
and satanic
dark magic and hell demonic stuff and
then
at the end it was just like but no we
never still didn't pan out right
it's kind of harder to see in falcon in
the winter soldier i was like hoping it
would be as like kind of easy
easy i guess whatever to read as um one
division was but falcon and winter
soldier is kind of hard because there's
also so many different branches to it
that i'm like because the last scene
with torrez in the last episode i was
just like
oh so he's just gonna become falcon now
we're gonna falcon him and i was like
are we
what are we doing what are we doing so
it's there's just so much it could be
i'm sorry zola hasn't shown up yet well
i think i don't think he will but uh i
think what we're
discovering with these first two disney
plus series is that
the arc of the series is being um
crafted by show runners and directors
and writers
who are just trying to tell their story
following a character's journey
with one division it was wanda's
overcoming her grief with uh falcon
winter soldier it's about sam
understanding the meaning of the shield
and whether he feels uh
worthy of carrying it and whether he
feels like he's the right guy to
carry that shield um and then when it
comes to how it sets up the broader mcu
it really is just kevin feige being like
do this and this is the post-credits
scenes
and then everything else will just
figure out in the exposition of the
first stack to the next game
you know so uh it's really we just have
those
that one or two scenes that come after
the credits to really tell us everything
we need to know
and make the next dozen videos on this
channel
well a ton of great stuff there um i it
makes me even more excited to go into
this uh
this final episode to see if any of this
comes true
um you know we'll be screaming if any of
it is right
but uh all three of you guys had some
really great theories there
let's see i feel like uh tom i gotta
give you some credit for
the the gear daily ice cream connection
with justin hammer
i'm not gonna reach but it's my kind of
reach yeah there we go thanks
harris i'm gonna give you a point for uh
seeing the connections there with the
power broker
uh and uh but also bringing up the zola
train there because i think we all
wanted it
but you got to have your safety theory
and your reach theory you know that's
just like applying to college
and then uh jessica i think you were the
first one to bring up the idea of it of
the sister of shanxi's sister being
as important as she is and that was
someone who barely appeared in the
shanghai trailer
but man if she could be connected if she
could be the power broker i think that
would be a really cool role for her as
well so let me give you a point as well
[Music]
yeah everything's pink with these on and
it's giving me a headache
but i'm doing it for the i'm doing it
for the looks
i'm doing it look through everything
everything in rose tinted glasses
eventually you're gonna get a headache
that's true oh nostalgia is a poison
damn you're my therapist now
damn and it's free but hey this week we
also got some huge casting news for the
upcoming marvel disney plus series
secret invasion everyone's in this show
now so we're going to talk about what we
think they're doing
there but first uh we want to thank some
uh people and tell you about some stuff
we're excited about
uh we're excited to announce that we
have a new falcon in the winter soldier
inspired shirt and our latest obsession
collection over at new
rockstarsmerch.com
this is a zemo inspired design it looks
great we rushed this guy out based on
the first half of the season it uh it
seeks to answer the question of who's
really pulling the strings
now there is a limited supply so you got
to grab one real quick before we have to
put it back in the dungeon with our
previous shirt designs
and check out this mid-season shirt oh
also check out this shirt that i'm
wearing this is our anarchy assembled
shirt
uh all other kinds of great merch at
newarkstersmerch.com now
uh we want to thank some sponsors here
uh today's episode is brought to you by
away travel who create thoughtful
products for every traveler and every
kind of trip
if you're like me you're itching to
travel again and see something that's
not just
out your window you know no matter what
your destination style
aways suitcases bags and accessories all
come in a variety of color sizes and
materials
to suit your needs and inspire your
future travels away products are
designed to last a lifetime if any part
of your suitcase breaks away
standout customer service team will
arrange to have it fixed or replaced
there is a 100-day trial on everything
away makes take it out on the road and
put it to the test
if you decide it's not for you you can
return any non-personalized item for a
full refund during that period
away offers free shipping and returns on
any order within the contiguous us
uk europe and canada so start your 100
day trial and shop the entire away
lineup of travel essentials including
their best-selling suitcases
at awaytravel.com rogue that's
travel dot com slash rogue we also want
to thank our friends at upstart for
sponsoring this episode if you dread
looking at your credit card statement
every month
upstart can help lift that weight off
your shoulders upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personalized loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple fixed monthly
payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score
like your income your employment history
this means that they can offer smarter
rates with trusted partners
with a five-minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
000
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
rogue theory that's upstart.com rogue
theory
don't forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
roguepiery and finally we want to thank
expressvpn for sponsoring this episode
most of us have very little choice an
internet service provider because isps
operate kind of like monopolies in the
regions they serve
they use this monopoly power to take
advantage of customers with data caps
and streaming throttles and worst of all
many isps log your internet activity and
then sell that data to other big tech
companies or advertisers
to prevent isps from seeing my internet
activity i protect my devices with
expressvpn
it's an app for your computer or
smartphone that encrypts all of your
network data and tunnels it
through a secure vpn server expressvpn
is the best way to hide your online
activity from your isp just download the
app tap one button and you are protected
and expressvpn does all of this
without slowing your connection that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by cnet and wired
so stop handing over your personal data
to isps and other tech giants who mine
your activity and sell off your
information
protect yourself with the vpni trust to
keep me private online
visit expressvpn.com rogue that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
rogue to get three extra months free go
to expressvpn.com
rogue right now to learn more all right
guys let's talk about secret invasion
uh i'm getting more and more excited for
this show as they keep announcing what
other big name is gonna be in it
the cast for this disney plus secret
invasion series is filling in we got
olivia coleman uh the queen of england
from uh from netflix's crown
uh and uh just a hilarious actress who's
been in everything oscar winner
uh as well as game of thrones amelia
clark
daenerys stormborn both of them are
going to be in undisclosed roles of the
show now we already knew
kingsley bennett dear was going to be
playing the villain of the series on top
of nick fury
and taylor's returning you could have
told me samuel jackson and ben
mendelsohn were in this show and no one
else and i would watch it
on top of that we got all these other
big names so we're filling in so uh
meanwhile we're seeing scrolls
everywhere in the mcu there was the one
who appeared in the one division
post-credits scene another scroll
appears in the loki trailer and then uh
lately in the falcon the winter soldier
we got
uh julie louis-dreyfus says contessa
valentina allegra de fontaine
joined the mcu she has a role in the
secret invasion prelude comics she's
actually
one of the first people who gets swapped
out for a scroll that nick fury catches
up on and he realizes that this whole
secret invasion is underfoot uh so i
want to ask you guys
who do you think everyone is playing or
who like uh
starting to cast some of these people
for me and uh how do we think recent
events are setting up the secret
invasion to really take over the full
mcu is it fair to say that everybody's a
scroll
i mean my my thing that i've taken from
this was secret invasion obviously nick
fury's going to kind of be the linchpin
for all of this because he has the
history
going back to captain marvel uh an
understanding of the scrolls
in this world i think this will
obviously be our introduction to some of
the bad scrolls
that we haven't seen yet and we're going
to find out they that
over time they have just almost like
hydra they've
infiltrated everything even at the
highest of levels the the skulls
are or scrolls excuse me are there so
that's where i'm taking from it so when
you you say castings like this
when you talk olivia coleman when you
say emilia clarke i'm thinking
i i would be i would be bummed if they
weren't scrolls right
right so yeah but it wouldn't surprise
me if uh if kingsley
isn't just because he's a villain maybe
he's a human that's manipulating
everything that's been going on
in the in the background right so i'm
pretty excited for it because this is
clearly going to change your perception
of the mcu because there's a pretty good
chance there's going to be a prominent
character that we've seen
in the past turns out it was a scroll
the whole time yeah
that's what i'm excited about i think i
agree and disagree
that's every time that's anytime i enter
any conversation i agree
but also i disagree i do i think it's
going to be the same kind of math where
i'm like
oh this one of them has to be a human
but i think that human is going to be
olivia coleman
and i think i think ultimately olivia
coleman because she's the crown she's
the favorite
she's playing and like even in fleabags
she's just like this woman that holds so
much power
and her just like her presence is
already like
not like egotistical but it's just like
i
demand respect so i think she's gonna be
a director someone that even if like
nick fury comes back he's gonna have to
talk to and she's gonna be like no we're
not
doing this um i don't know what director
of what
there's so much people how about abigail
brand director
there you go thank you thanks i should
have said that
i call i claim it god damn it i should
have said i didn't even think about that
i was like i don't know who it is the
person that people have been begging for
and freaking one division so i think it
could be
yeah it could be her but then i also
think like amelia clark would probably
play
well i assumed that kingsley would be
the um
would be the super squirrel the collar
whatever
i just assumed he'd be like the
strongest scroll of them all and then i
assumed that um
emilia clarke would play the queen
veronkey or whatever
because she's also gorgeous and she's
great
but i do think that's where we're
meeting with i
i think falcon and soldier will help
with the super soldier serum and how
there's a bunch of random superhumans in
the world
that's the people that they're taking
and like dissecting and trying to like
mimic they're trying to mimic all the
super soldiers that are we
have now seen in falcon and winter
soldier does this
help anything i was missing it but now i
get it thanks
yeah so i think that's where it's coming
from
um no i i'm i'm gonna agree with both of
you uh i think that
um you know uh i think that they're most
likely maybe they'll play human cells
but i think they might be
the skrulls most likely i'm i'm i was
thinking the same thing as you jessica
that
um kingsley benadir would be maybe a
super skrull and they we could be
setting him up for more roles in
fantastic four which is now coming down
the line because with the squirrels
really uh coming to a head now in the
mcu that's got to tie into the
fantastic four at some point and people
were thinking reid richards was going to
be in one division i was like that's a
little early maybe but i did i was a
believer
i was like i believe you really don't
have that
so now though now i'm like okay now we
could be starting to set some chess
pieces in place for uh the fantastic
four um
and it's funny before the before amelia
clarke was announced i was like oh maybe
julia louis dreyfus val will be uh
varanke because
you know she as a she uh she has a
history of as a being a squirrel in the
comics maybe she's a squirrel in this
universe too and then
if they make her uh have a relationship
with nick fury
that would add more stakes to you know
nick fury finding out she's a squirrel
and and how that comes to a head in that
show um
but now that they've got daenerys on
board i'm like oh well that's she's got
to be frank
and olivia coleman you know another
queen on the show
like so maybe maybe olivia coleman will
be like the queen squirrel who's like in
charge of
everything yeah daenerys is like the
up-and-coming
young queen and you know through uh her
own will and the strength will end up
taking over and
about daenerys will be the one to uh
invade earth and start all of this stuff
but um yeah so i like both those here
that i think that uh i think it's gonna
be somewhere in between there
that's the one thing that i'm confused
about is when
contessa showed up in falcon and water
soldier i was like
where is she going and i'm still like
very confused like
yeah she's going to be in well do you
know
well again i'm i'm just holding on to to
my hope
and i'm sure it'll be crushed when
episode 6 comes out
i think she's acting on on
she's acting as a lieutenant for
thunderbolt ross i think she's putting
together that's what i was thinking
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
okay i was so confused i was like where
is our character gonna go in this
i like that too obviously know the
legacy that potentially she could show
up in secret invasion and everything on
that but
it seems to me the bigger play
especially since we know she was
supposed to be in black widow
we saw the conversation she had with
john walker we know where
um we know where uh zemo is headed to
the raft which is controlled by ross
it almost seems like she's acting on his
behalf to set up
his own group to be able to do the
things that
you know uh falcon and bucky would be
unwilling to do
right yeah we have when we're taping
this it will be tomorrow when it comes
out but by the time you're watching this
it'll be yesterday's video yeah i
i tried to piece together the all the
clues we saw
for how she could be involved in a
thunderbolts plot and to me it just
seems like the fact that she's
eager to recruit john walker
a super soldier juiced up guy uh and the
fact that zemo's going to the raft it's
kind of we have like these two strands
of things that are going in kind of
similar directions
and i'm wondering if like they would
have named her victoria hand
if not for the fact that like victorian
was already in agents of shield and they
didn't want any confusion there
uh and two if olivia coleman is playing
abigail
abigail brand they didn't want to just
have two similar sounding new stunt
castings in the mcu of
abigail brand victoria hand you know
yeah
and screenwriting you kind of try to
change up your characters names as much
as you can
one other theory that i had and i'm
wondering is i still i
agree that you know marvel's really been
planting the seeds for
some kind of scroll action like every
property we've had up to this point has
a skrull stinger if not they're part of
the
part of the movie itself so yeah yeah i
was thinking kind of like the comics uh
how it ended civil war to kind of lead
into secret invasion
my other theory that relates to winter
soldier is what if
you know sharon carter who's maybe the
power broker she's obviously
broken bad she's evil what if she
will be revealed to be a skrull um you
know that could explain the bad behavior
and if she dies in this in this next
episode which you might already know if
you're watching or
if not it's coming out tonight if she
dies like you know then her squirrel
body
could be what brings them to be like
what's happening and that could be the
stinger
kind of like how that that's fun pagon
pagon i think is the name of the skrull
who was elektra who was
served the same purpose the electra
scroll that when she died was a scroll
and revealed that
what's going on we have this what's
happening and i think sharon might be
able to fit that role too and that would
then give
you know more credence to why sharon
carter is acting so weird without
hitting the nail on the head if she's a
power broker right
yeah or something else happening i mean
i'll say going into this series i
like sharon carter was up at the top of
uh the list i had for who would be a
possibility
girl just because she's such a blank
canvas you know or
totally you know and she's been around
for a while we know maria hill has uh
in the past swapped around with a scroll
um but like at this point who do you
guys think if not sharon carter uh
like for me like roadie's kind of at the
top of my list i always thought that
yeah yeah he's been a big one for me it
and and they would give you that tie
back
all the way to iron man one that happens
here's tony stark's best friend was a
scroll the entire time
look that'd be messed up this is the
part this is the first secret invasion
that i know i'm gonna be so frustrated
in
and i'm sure everyone will be of being
like are they human or are they scroll
like just constantly being like what are
they are they human or are they scroll
one thing i kind of thought a while
about was that yeah similar to the you
know to the war machine like that they
would treat some of the recasting they
had to do
as a squirrel kind of situation you know
that would make sense with the don
cheadle thing and you know but then they
would have to then explain more terrence
howard stuff but
yeah there's i think they're gonna have
to pick a lot of uh characters like
maybe even side people
kind of like how jarvis in the comics
was ended up being a skrull but they
can't do that now
does it have to be someone from the like
original core
the original doesn't have to i just feel
like that's where it's coming up
yeah i think both right like i think
it's going to be new people who come to
the scene
but like if you got to think what made
secret invasions so exciting the comics
is like
people who we've been with for years and
i think that's what excites kevin feige
and the people working on the show the
most about of like
who in the mcu that's who the mcu could
we reveal to be a squirrel without
pissing a bunch of people off that's
kind of the dance
right that's true i mean and they could
be going that's why i liked veronkey a
lot because when she was playing
uh jessica drew spiderman yeah but
and also they don't have to follow the
comic but though i think news sources
have been like this is the one that like
follows the comics
really well and completely i don't know
if that's true but
it i i think they could still change up
those things slightly
like she could be playing she wouldn't
be like monica
but she could be don cheadle she could
be she could end up being rhodes the
entire time
yeah i mean and it's kind of hard
because yes super squirrels exist but
that's like a step beyond just revealing
someone's a shape-shifting alien
they're gonna have to start with someone
who's just like presumably a normal
human
yeah but that's why i was thinking that
you know it would be
like val would probably be a good
contestant because amelia clark is great
and fantastic but
but the the fun part about uh varanke is
like you know she was somebody now she's
somebody else so it would have to just
be switching an actor and all of a
sudden
amelia clark and now i'm the one who's
i've been the scroll the whole time
versus if it's someone like val or even
you know um you know war machine it's
somewhat you know like it's someone
we've
we know and are already attached to in
that sense you know it's not and it's
not just
morphing into emilia clarke it's like
some other actor and some other person
that we've already seen real talk yeah
yeah real talk
was it was it you just now jessica who
said happy hogan could be a scroll yeah
uh i'm gonna give you a point for that
that is i want fat bro
looking in a mirror shape-shifting into
a scroll would be such an amazing reveal
and wouldn't piss off anybody we'd be
like
whatever he was kind of all right let us
now look ahead to our rogue questions we
have a couple questions uh everybody can
answer these so are you guys ready
okay so zack snyder revealed in an
interview over the weekend that the
original title that he wanted for batman
v superman dawn of justice was
son of sun night
of night i'm gonna quote him
my question is what is the most
pretentious title you can think of for
batman
that is that's really pretentious that
is honestly
the pretty pretty so stupid if i knew
him i'd walk to his house right now
and say thank you or what would you say
oh no
i'd slap him
zach let's sit down we know you're good
enough you can come up with a better
title than that
but that is still better than bvsdoj
oh girl a more pretentious title than
that okay let me think okay okay
okay okay hear me out hear me out
what is this it's so stupid it makes no
sense
what if he called it like
earth wind and fire and then these plane
earth wind and fire on the trailer
soundtrack and each earth wind fire
represents
[Laughter]
i don't know which one batman would be
earth i guess um
put a wonder woman as a as uh
no fire no fire no that makes more sense
that fire um and then superman could we
win
i guess but then like they could add
water and it would be aquaman i don't
i'm trying to think of something so
corny and stupid i think that's pretty
good and it's like do you remember
but in like slow motion okay
we'll slow it down dark piano cover of
it
[Music]
this is probably terrible but what if it
was something like
sun s-u-n falls to
the night k-i-n-g-h-t i don't know that
it's just
that's good that one's better
oh pretty pretentious yeah that's up
there i was i was going between two
well it could be like superman and
batman returns
to play on both of those movies i have a
return or
or you could just not even call it
superman batman vs batman you can call
it just
dawn of martha and nothing else and
everyone will have to be
what is the title of that it won't be
till the end that you are to that
pivotal moment where you find out that
this was the dawn of
martha i have a second one to add to
mine
so what if he because i thought about it
what if he just stole
another title and he called it nightman
cometh
and and only fans of its only it's
always sonny in philadelphia
knew what he was talking about but
they're talking about batman
night man i'm trying to think of
something as stupid as the sun and sun
one i'm very upset about it how about a
play on lois lois and clark the tv show
so
it's bruce and clark the fight for
justice
the new adventures of super fast i love
the idea of lois and clark
like lewis and clark just the super
friends there that actually could do
that too
lois and clark oh my god i love this uh
many great answers there i have to give
the point to
um the night man cometh just again
almost honestly slightly better than his
original idea of the title
he is so stupid exactly why would you do
that
like he's my friend why would you be
there coming for you
okay don't get me wrong go ahead but
that title is ridiculous you guys
that title is ridiculous right
yeah feels like a first draft first it
was it was it was definitely like the he
made the script and then he was like
damn i gotta freaking title this
and waited like he drank like four cold
brews and was like okay
titles are hard leave it leave it to the
marketing people to come with titles i
don't know here's my story
i you guys make me feel like the people
are going to come at me on the comments
i got in a fight with a bunch of people
yesterday because their favorite batman
is the george clooney batman
who are these people how did they how
dare you
how did they figure out how to use
twitter thank you
oh my god i'm going to clip this and i'm
going to share it everywhere i was like
y'all
i thought we all knew that that one was
like the they were trolling
you know he got a bad credit card
listen here alvin on the clips i am so
thank you
i was taken thank you you guys glasses
are on she's serious guys
um all right we have one more question
so the oscars are this weekend
so your challenges you can give out any
oscar you like
including a made-up category to a film
that you liked in 2020
oh it's not even made up sonic the
hedgehog for best picture because it's
the only movie i saw in 2020.
in theaters i assume right you can watch
stuff on streaming okay
yeah but yes it it might have been
it's like one of five movies i got to
see in the theater in 2020 for sure
i would give a best oscar performance
for uh best streaming show
cry to sebastian stan at the wakanda
fire
that part where he's getting it wiped
from him i was like
oh all of a sudden this show just got so
real and i feel so although it's not a
comic book show anymore i feel so bad
for this guy who's been hurt for so long
and i was like somebody give sebastian
stan an award i need to see that i was
uh gonna say along
the same lines as tom and be like give
them like a
tv like one tv category which you know
if the oscars did that
they'd rap in with musical and comedy
because they don't know where to put
those two for some reason
and i think they should give it to um
um elizabeth olsen in one division uh
because her acting was
incredible and she didn't even get
anything you know we have an award show
for tv right
no we don't even
no no i don't know what you're talking
about um i only watched the
oscars are nothing yeah i only
watch the academy awards what's wrong
with you
well i gotta give the point to paris
it's the only one who mentioned a movie
sorry i'm sorry
and a movie that came out i think
actually in 2019.
no it's not it came out february 2020.
whatever we all saw it and we all cried
and we loved it
okay wonderful i was ready to fight i
was ready it came out 12 years ago
in 2016. 2020. yeah despite that jessica
you had the most points making
you the winner of today's rogue theory
i don't want to do my own horn but this
is my second time in a row
well that is it for this episode of
rogue theory this is such a fun episode
i love chatting uh the falcon where
soldier in chongqi and secret invasion
with you guys i can't wait to have you
guys back next time so we can
uh see how right and wrong we were about
our theories i'm sure it's all gonna be
right
um thank you so much to all of our
guests uh jessica clemons
paris lilly tom michelson uh support all
three of them by following them on their
social medias uh
and supporting all their various
projects uh all three are working on
amazing things and very funny talented
people so
support them wherever they are you can
support our channel by
checking out one of our many great merch
options at nyrockstarsmerch.com you can
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
here on us what are we on we're on
youtube right now yeah that's where we
are
but uh we're on other platforms as well
follow us there uh
and uh subscribe to us and we will see
you next time bye-bye everybody
[Music]
you